live's matter demonstrations broke out
over the summer after the killing of
george floyd
an unknown black man killed in police
custody all this week we're examining
what
changes metro police have made and what
still needs to be done
bianca holman tells us how a local
chapter of the black police officers
association
is influencing the force las vegas
chapter has become like the
chapter when it comes to events and
a lot of other states they look up to us
to see what we're doing
this is the willie smoot award one of
several the las vegas chapter of the
black police officers association
bpoa has won through the years because
of their events like back to school
fairs
holiday programs and most recently
drive-through food banks regina
coward-holman is the local
chapter president and was a metro
officer for more than 20 years
service is over everything because if
you can't serve
you're not going to be effective coward
holmen and current officer adrian hunt
realize their race and background
influences the job that's our job we
failed is to just to bridge the
community
um you know that we grew up in and to
show them hey
you know that we're here you know and
we're regular people just like you guys
founded in 1972 the bpoa's mission is to
be the conscious of the criminal justice
system
advocate for officers of color and
improve the quality of life in the black
community
and in the black community the excessive
use of force by police is a reoccurring
issue
the death of george floyd an unarmed
black man killed in police
custody and the death of brianna taylor
triggered protests around the country
our national chair she was on every talk
show that she could possibly get on to
get the message out and the message is
about
being accountable black men are twice as
likely to die in an interaction with
police than white men that's according
to a report in the american journal of
public health
in addition black people make up only 7
percent of metro's police force
and 10 percent of the entire staff
including civilians
officer hunt says that's a cause for
concern my thing is to always push and
push
into you know to get more people who
look like me
to join the department metro has a
multicultural advisory council that
provides
feedback to the sheriff monthly however
coward holmen says black
officers should be at the table with
leadership more often and help train the
department when it comes to racial
issues
she says frequent cultural awareness
classes can save lives
who better to teach these classes than
the people who work for you
who actually know both sides of the
story coward holmen says tension
embedded in our country's history
can only be healed by working together
we've been
in this community pounding the sand for
20 years but for the last eight years
we've been pounding it hard because we
have to make a change
and the department can't do it by
themselves reporting bianca holman
8 news now tomorrow night the i-team's
vanessa murphy will be looking at use of
force policies and also how complaints
against metro police officers
are investigated those reports are
coming up at 5 and 11 o'clock
and we also have more information on
police use of force
hirings and firings and diversity on the
force on 8newsnow.com
just be sure to click on the banner on
the front page that says the state of
metro
metro police